We do have big news that I don't want to go
overly crazy about because of how it will
probably turn out.
The big news is that Donald Trump's former
national security advisor, one of Trump's
former national security advisors, John Bolton,
one of the architects of the Iraq war says
he's willing to testify in the Senate impeachment
trial of Donald Trump.
He says he would do it if he is subpoenaed.
That's typical in these situations to say
you will show up if you are subpoenaed, uh,
because you don't want to be accused of willingly
showing up to bad mouth someone, but it's
not totally clear that that's actually what
John Bolton would do.
We just don't know.
Bolton said in a statement yesterday quote,
I have concluded that if the Senate issues
a subpoena for my testimony, I am prepared
to testify.
Now, of course, whether he would be subpoenaed
by a Republican Senate is a real open question.
Republicans are likely to run the trial as
Mitch McConnell has admitted in the way that's
most beneficial to Donald Trump after Bolton
and Trump's falling out.
It's very difficult to imagine that a Bolton
testimony would actually be in Donald Trump's
interest.
But nevertheless, Trump, uh, a Bolton rather
publicly saying this does put some pressure
on Republicans, uh, to bring them in.
Now, Marco Rubio, Republican Senator from
Florida came up with a completely cockamamie
excuse for why he doesn't think Bolton should
testify.
It was something about, I'm paraphrasing here,
I think he said it's a Manu Rajo of CNN.
It was something along the lines of, well,
the impeachment articles were based not on
John Bolton's testimony.
So I think that the impeachment trial in the
Senate should be based on the same things
that the articles were voted on in the house.
Sort of saying like, if Bolton wasn't part
of the proceedings in the house, he shouldn't
be called in the Senate.
It was ridiculous.
You know, a number of different legal analyses
say it makes no sense whatsoever.
Now, as an update, uh, the president has been
impeached by the house of representatives,
speaker of the house.
Nancy Pelosi has not yet sent the articles
of impeachment, both.
There's two of them, uh, to the Senate, which
is required to get the trial going.
Remember that John Bolton previously declined
to participate in the house's impeachment
investigation saying that he was directed
by the Trump administration not to comply
with Congress.
He said, if you subpoena me, if federal courts
uphold the subpoena, I will testify the committees
ultimately did not issue a subpoena for his
testimony.
Now there is something interesting about the
subpoena of John Bolton.
Many things in the Senate require a two thirds
majority to impeach a president and convict
them.
In the Senate.
You need a two thirds majority.
You need two thirds of senators, meaning 67
of the a hundred senators to vote to convict.
Right now there are 45 Democrats and two independents
who caucus with Democrats.
That's 47 votes in the Senate.
You would need 20 Republican senators vote
to convict in order to remove Donald Trump,
not likely to happen to subpoena John Bolton.
You need only a simple majority meaning 51
senators.
That means you need the 45 Democrats.
The two independents who caucus with Democrats,
Bernie Sanders and Angus King, and then just
for Republicans to sign on to subpoena John
Bolton.
You actually could make this happen.
If we go to our standard list of Republicans
who might do something logical.
You've got Susan Collins from Maine, you've
got Lisa Murkowski from Alaska.
You've gotten maybe Mitt Romney, uh, from
Utah.
People talk about over about what, about Cory
Gardner from Colorado.
It's possible.
The idea of Bolton being willing to testify
if subpoenaed is also funny.
If you are subpoenaed, you were required by
law to show up.
They're talking about it like it's a choice
and he would make the right choice.
Now that's an issue that maybe will come up
if, um, uh, Bolton is unwilling to respond
to the subpoena, or if it is challenged by
the white house and it goes to federal courts,
but Donald Trump clearly will do what he can
to prevent John Bolton from ultimately testifying.
Imagine being Bolton who has loved the idea
of war with Iran for so long and now Trump
waits until you're gone before trying to start
a war with Iran.
He must just be furious and his neo-con boots.
Don't you think?
Now as far as people getting super excited
about Bolton's testimony, even if he's subpoenaed
and even if the subpoena is upheld by a federal
court and Bolton has to testify, he could
choose to obfuscate unimportant issues.
He could plead the fifth unimportant issues.
Bolton will do what is best for John Bolton
and that might be showing up in obfuscating.
It might be showing up in self aggrandizing.
It might be showing up and saying nothing.
This guy is, not only is he no hero, he's
really one of the villains of American foreign
policy over the last 20 years and of course
of the Iraq war.
The only good thing here is that it puts a
little bit of pressure on Senate majority
leader Mitch McConnell to allow witnesses
because otherwise it would look like they
are trying to silence Bolton, which they probably
are.
But once again, if there's no consequences
for silencing John Bolton, why wouldn't they
do it?
It wouldn't
make
a difference.